for me this is really one of the biggest
tasks right now as intellectuals is
realizing in our own life there are so
many things were not proud of and we're
trying to hide from people and sometimes
that provokes a little bit of aggression
and rather ugly behavior and we behave
in a way we're not proud of at all and
then we get even less proud of ourselves
and then that cycle gets even worse it's
very good to remember every single
person you're meeting is also in the
same situation and rather than simply
reacting to how obnoxious they are and
how much you hate them at that moment
recognize they're just hiding some
ridiculous horrible thing from you and
are really uncomfortable and for me the
big task now is to realize the space
between you and the person you imagine
yourself as which is sometimes quite
fast most days we're really not the
person we imagine ourselves as or we
would like to imagine ourselves as and
nor are the people were meeting and I
think our task now is to meet each other
in such a way that each gives the other
permission to become the person they
wanted to be not to be judged by what
they're doing now because what they're
doing now is a mistake and they know
that but to create a creative space a
space where nobody loses face and
everybody has a chance to start again
from a better place and do something
more helpful
human beings need that space and we
don't give it to ourselves and we don't
give it to each other that we don't even
give it to ourselves as incredible as as
the great Muslim philosopher al-ghazali
says when you really think of it it
breaks your heart but of course it
doesn't break your heart because your
heart is so hard that you don't even
have a soft heart towards yourself let
alone to other people go ahead let your
heart break I think right now we're in a
period where people are so frightened
they won't even let the heartbreak
because of course the situation in Syria
the situation in so many places it just
breaks your heart if your heart is not
broken by that something's wrong with
your heart and meanwhile once you break
your heart and let your heart break it
changes how you respond if I may just go
to the heart of what I think we're
trying to get in the history of art is a
history of art is about one primary
primary primary primary primary primary
understanding which is what would it be
like to be that other person theatre was
invented so you start to think oh that's
what it would be like to be that person
literature was invented so you would
think oh that's what it would be like to
be that person music was invented so you
think that's what it would be like to be
that person and guess what that person
is me
and if there had been artists in certain
rooms no one would have ever green
lighted torture in the Green Zone and
then ever gripe and the drone strikes in
was ariston and all these things where
somebody couldn't imagine what that
would be like if that was your daughter
or your son so I would just emphasize
that in fact the ability to imagine what
it's like for another person to go
through something is not a luxury item
it's actually the only possible way to
be alive is to recognize what the person
you're talking to you is thinking
instead of what you think you're saying
to them because what you think you're
saying to them is not what they're
hearing if you haven't noticed haha
they're really hearing something else'
and if all you can think of is what
you're saying you have a problem this
active imagination is not just a
survival skill it's crucial to moving
economic political or any other type of
policy forward again if it's your
grandmother who lost her home and you're
running these banks and these mortgages
for goodness sakes
but that somebody can simply say oh this
is what the law is the real discipline
is getting out of our habits of
oppositional thinking because if you are
still thinking oppositional e you are so
badly dated and you're so damn useless
because any project that doesn't include
your enemy is not going to work period
so first of all you have to figure out
how to cross the bridge into their
neighborhood you have to figure out how
to be the friend of someone who you
really dislike you have to figure out
how to have a real conversation with
someone instead of just yell at them you
have to suddenly get way better at
listening and you have to go to that
place where you say okay these two
opposing schools of thought where could
they meet what little point would give
us a piece of shared ground they would
let us have a conversation with
integrity and would say okay we can both
live in the same neighborhood even
though we deeply disagree but we share
this point this point at that point
which is an intellectual discipline and
we don't get ourselves into this
all-or-nothing mentality and we don't
buy into the nightmare of white
supremacy or any kind of supremacy the
people you don't like have a reason to
be here
the people you oppose deeply have an
equal reason to be here now until we
figure that out we are just as benighted
as the people we think are bonide it and
that is a giant intellectual and
spiritual project is to find light and
possibility everywhere and again to
create the conditions where people are
engaging in monstrous things have a
chance to do something else and to put
it a very direct way the person you
think is the problem or the country you
think is the problem or the neighborhood
you think is the problem even in your
own family that person who's the problem
is the only solution and there will be
no solution until that person is the
solution